There's a great line
by Albert Camus.
He says, life should be
lived to the point of tears.
In other words, we should strive
to be moved, to be transported,
to be shaken.
We all want to be
touched by something
greater than ourselves.
That's a difficult thing to do.
And so I've become
really obsessed
with the idea of experience
design, which is basically
hacking experience,
hacking subjectivity.
Now, what is experience?
What is first
person subjectivity?
Well, in a way, it's
that evanescent flux
of sensation and perception
that is, in a way, all we have
and all we are.
It's the
multi-dimensional matrix
of first person experience
unfolding moment by moment.
It's the voice in our head that
lets us know that we exist.
So how can we inform, how
can we script that narrative?
How can we be the director of
our own movies, so to speak?
And it turns out that
the trick is attention.
To hack experience, you've
got to hack attention.
In a fantastic article
by Diana Slattery
says that what is required
is the capture and control
of attention to create a
state of deep immersion,
of deep absorption.
And this kind of immersion
is the prerequisite
for any kind of interpersonal
persuasion, transformation,
or education to take place.
In other words, any kind of
phase change in consciousness,
any kind of true inspiration,
transformation, catharsis
requires this deep
immersion, this state
of focused attention.
And again, that being
the key to experience,
that being the key to scripting
subjectivity, the narrative
of your own life, and that
seems to be ultimately
the key to happiness,
the meaning of our lives,
this kind of deconstructing
of our consciousness
and tweaking our
perceptual apparatus.
To kind of engineer a
kind of neural nirvana,
to trade in real virtualities,
to trade in subjectivities,
that is what it
means to be human.
And that is what we are
increasingly becoming masters
at doing, at distilling, at
creating, and I love that.